[Musica]
la riconoscete vero e proprio la musica
del mio funerale questa cioè senso
quando muoio questa musica cioè perché
non può esserci altro immagino bene a
tutti ragazzi beve solo video che sono
tra un posto non uno shock però adesso
sono fa ejeie siamo tornati su allora
siccome ultimamente stavo giocando i
livelli più belli miei inutilmente di
coltivare a farlo perché c'è talmente
tanta differenza tra un livello e
l'altro non è vero oggi facciamo quelli
di problematiche sono belli anche questi
non mi fraintendete pro mammamia quelli
che ci sono nella parte della specie
nella parte iniziale ma guardava un
altra roba proprio lei o toole nissan
180 sx 1990 che immagino sia l'anno in
cui è stata fatta male che non me ne
frega niente perché non mi intendo di
macchine poi soprattutto stiamo giocando
epico siamo una gran torino quindi chi
se ne frega però ottimo sonoro a questa
è la gara
dov'è il tifo dov'è il rumore del motore
dove tutta sta roba non c'è io mi sento
pieno di adrenalina
non so come fare a contenermi a aiuto e
la mia vita è fatta di pericoli
sono contento bene abbiamo livello 89
per cento il prossimo
partiamo con un il prossimo perché
quella roba di prima facciamo i die non
sia partiti neanche impossible il
prossimo dovrebbe essere quest'ultima mi
si vuole un pò strano effettivamente
pieno non vogliamo non vogliamo la
finale o nella wsr in quella per pro
gamer quella che faceva anche i ninja
anche lui faceva sta roba qua time to
say my sun tempo di salvare mio figlio
ma che cosa me ne frega a parte che non
è figlio mio
ma avvisami circoli sta lì e non ma
vince il sul mio muoio perché così ma
avvisami no che c'è un articolo di no
gen arpione non me lo diceva non me lo
dire piano qua con gli altri secondo me
sono morto però dovrei controllare bene
per sicurezza ma ve lo chiedo per
cortesia tumori e gli alpini fatemi una
vita
comunque mio figlio non viene tratto non
si sa come mai questo un problema world
tra un più secret mamma mia che pose
incredibili della gente allora ok
aspetta che prendo la camera stessa
mi sono girato dall'altra parte mannaia
no devo fare così però va bene niente
sarebbe stato veramente figo però non
sono ancora arrivati a questi livelli di
tecnologia cielo lo schalke che se la
gode vale tieni tu la vuoi che ti regalo
un bambino l'anno dopo era prendi ecco
perché non vuole bambini non prova
niente
clive tuma youtube channel natasha
mi dispiace ma non lo farò però vediamo
che video fai bene interessato sento e
vedo che comunque di happy with the ne
intende e lasciamo perdere natascha now
su un altro livello
grazie natasha non hai fatto questo
questa cosa quale preferisci vultur eder
allora va bene facciamo vuol dire ter
sul web in sala la fifa 19 o pesi 19
allora io tra i due film ora sono
rimasto da tempo fa giocavo un sacco a
pezzi ma tipo vi sto parlando di quando
ero piccolo adesso non ci gioco molto a
calcio ma se devo giocare gioca fifa
però quest'anno
siccome c'è il piemonte calcio e non la
juve non lo so però viva piemonte calcio
rho blocks e happy riforma non faremo
solo andando cda 5 o gta san andreas
allora ragazzi tutti voi preferite gta 5
ma io perché sono nato non l'altro ieri
e preferisco di cassandra ma di mille
volte cosa preferisci poco fight like
you prof
[Musica]
[Applauso]
c'è un livello si è sbattuto un sacco
per farlo complimenti va bene non ho mai
capito se i livelli che li puoi fare il
marmo lento poi andare a giocare
lietamente sul gioco il sito apposta
però l'aveva facciamone slept with heart
un doge schiva gli arpioni va bene hai
visto che bravo immagino che ora bimba
stato folle
mamma mia proprio lui
madonna ragazze nate ad un fenomeno
soggiorno a posto sono uno sculaccia
tino ma con me ma com è a posto
ditemi the piccolo stesso rock swing
hanno dove andare avanti porca vacca era
l'ultimo livello rifacciamolo raga
questo mi è piaciuto perché difficile
come ha fatto a morire alla fine perché
è strano perché non non è vero nella
linea di tiro prove per adesso tutto che
non ero nella linea di tiro prima sono
morto a caso a ok benissimo occhio
sto bene è tutto ok vai vai a farmi
passare per favore grazie gentile
testata adesso se mourinho per la
testata sarebbe stato incredibile come
vero metro aveva tua sorella
davanti bikers training va bene
spiegamento spiegami
non solo capace di andare in bici basta
potremo fare dei fiori slava chiamano un
sacco che non faceva una roba assurda
florita va ma su happy wheels ai tempi
avrebbe fatto un miliardo di più se
avessi fatto devono di sla the floor il
naso pronunciarlo ragazzo si è avuto
problemi a pronunciare the floor e slava
ma se ci va ma non avevo dubbi alla
piano piano vabbè è veramente difficile
non mi sono salvato secondo me se faccio
così
madonna cos'ha fatto e guarda quello
dovrebbe essere il traguardo va bene ho
fatto come incredibile mi meritavo la
vittoria solo per questo gravissimo per
carinissimo calmissimo proprio lui
vai testa vinci i ragazzi sembrano dei
salami incastrati nel formaggio fuso la
lava prove o ragazzi il video è sicuro
che è veramente difficile se non ho mai
fatto livello così sta mettendo a dura
prova le mie skill da da happy with come
si chiamano i giocatori a ipv6 più
windsurf ok non ok perché mi sa che
voglio invece non sono morto ha fatto un
salto dritto pirla non ho creduto in me
stesso forse se riuscisse a saltare in
modo un po più ho preso una bottiglia ci
sono solo vivo sono anche la foto alla
bottiglia che non cade come possibile
capisco che listino la bottiglia mi ha
salvato la vita va bene non posso
livello veramente difficile cioè io poi
sono il mio punto debole i bar
consulting però il parkour servi
sicuramente vi giuro un casino ok
amen
la mia casa non so come ho fatto a
vincere ma l'importante è che tutto è
bene quel che finisce la la volete
vedere ragazzi il proroghe ming quello
vero così proprio ci credo
[Musica]
l'importante è crederci nella vita ho
sempre detto io chiamo su logic game 9 è
un gioco di logica quindi non credo di
poter nel senso lo devo creare un ponte
bene non è quello che pensavo che cosa
devo semplicemente tu a non fare niente
dove solo toglierlo capirla vabbè è il
primo ciò siamo tolto speed per 2 1 ce
lo siamo tolto tempo niente devo fare
cose sopravvivere ma io posso anche
muovermi va bene tutto qualcosa no ok a
posto occhio così l'azione non mi
colpisce questo lo staff sono bravissimo
guardali che pro gamer dai no ci abbiamo
provato non era un gioco di logica lo
sapevamo dall'inizio che sarebbe stato
difficile quindi pavè ai ragazzi
facciamo un paio di livelli miei se sei
uscito qualcosa nell'ultimo video che ho
fatto che non sente che la tua roba da
news
ok vediamo poi ci si è bello grazie
trama lo so grazie ragazzi hanno difatti
livelli mi sembra essere tornati vecchi
tempi francesco galaxy grazie mille
comunque ragazzi mi date a parlare
questo livello a fa vigeva tanto 5
stelle provateci anche voi perche
fattibile 99 laverone il prossimo va
bene amico mio vediamo se hai fatto
qualcosa di fattibile
questa potrebbe solo una vera sfida per
famigerato ragazzi ma cosa vi credete
dopo mille anni di harris però non era
male sta cosa
massei sicuri che sia fattibile proprio
lui non ho scritto due volte a volte
attenzione madonna ragazza come le skifo
gli arpioni alla fine impossibile eccolo
proprio lui mille anni disk il suo
giorno vale ragazzi per oggi va bene
faccio questo nel prossimo ne farò
magari un po di più di miei nel 2019 vi
siete dati da fare va bene ritengo anche
un po per i prossimi ragazzi per ora
concludo qua vi sia piaciuto grazie per
il livello come gli amari francesco
galaxy no era d'arca la bela da capron
francesca ha detto che sono bello grazie
grazie non c'è stato riferito francesca
ma fa niente va bene lo stesso se c'è
qualche francesca che pensa che io sia
bello me lo scriva nei commenti
iscrivetevi lasciato mi piace
schiacciate la campanella per essere
aggiornati sui treni dove escono
soprattutto anche in quelli di è finita
la prossima volta faccio quelli proprio
i migliori secondo il gioco che secondo
me e meritano però adesso
concludo qua e noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video e da ragazzi
[Musica]